oh boy did you see the newest Bill Gates
interview
oh ho you're gonna like this one this
look I don't know this person
interviewing him is but this [__] goes
in hard
one of the issues that's dog Jew is is
that of your relationship with Jeffrey
Epstein do you regret he really likes
you know what Bill Gates really likes
every time you bring up that after he
was convicted pedophile he had several
dinners with him so much so
that his wife said it was one of the
reasons they got divorced I believe at
one point his wife
I saw in an interview his wife
said uh in an interview after they got
divorced his wife was telling one of
this woman was interviewing her that
um
one time she asked to meet Jeffrey
Epstein because she wanted to know who
this guy was that Bill Gates kept
spending so much time with and she said
when she met him she was immediately
repulsively
I mean well she was like look I'm I'm
not saying she's a vegetarian she
approaches evil too but I do think
there's some people are just like no
thanks there's something about this guy
even if it's not preservation you could
because you could be evil and still be
like yeah I don't want him around my
kids or in this house exactly fair
enough
like you'll dump sewage you know out on
the [__] stick somewhere but not near
your Mansion exactly now one of the
issues that's dogged you is is that of
your relationship with Jeffrey Epstein
do you regret the relationship that you
maintained with him against Melinda's
advice and wishes I've said that I'm I
mean this is you're going way back in
time but yeah 2012. new audience I will
say for the you know over a hundredth
time yeah I shouldn't have had uh
dinners with him
you see how snarky he gets over a
hundred times it's a big deal this is
not like this is not like saying like
hey man when's Windows X5 coming out you
know what I mean this is uh more of a
hey you were the guy who probably got to
compromise like so many powerful people
people
um
had a way of sexually compromising
people is that what Melinda was warning
you about
I don't know who this reporter is but
you know kudos to her yeah
no
I mean it's
no that's stupid you're stupid I had
dinner with him uh and that's all
and that you regret the relationship the
acquaintance that I had dinner with them
and and the relationship between the
foundation and Epstein which there never
was any relationship
but there absolutely was
he though he
it's weird that you also have a
little onions about like the world and
depopulation is [__] Jeffrey Epstein
did as well it's kind of weird that you
guys agreed on a lot but not the
pedophile thing huh that's the only
thing you guys didn't agree on man
Jeffrey Epstein somebody who lives his
entire life with absolutely zero guilt
or remorse for what he did all of a
sudden had a moment of guilt and decided
to spontaneous kill himself with [__]
cameras around the guards were asleep
isn't that nuts
crazy I'm afraid I would say it's
unlikely I'm afraid people think Jeffrey
Epstein couldn't change
you're a [__] [__]
that child menu at chicolini's yeah the
kids menu at chicolini's
right probably the best [__] Jeffrey
Epstein joke I've ever heard slop him
sloppy sex trafficked minors
slop them up slap them up and pour water
on him